[Music]
when trains began to shuttle people
across the countryside many insisted
they would never replace horses less
than a century later people repeated
that same prediction about cars
telephones radio television and
computers each had their own host of
detractors even some experts insisted
they wouldn't catch mole of course we
can't predict exactly what the future
will look like or what new inventions
will populate it but time and time again
we've also failed to predict that the
technologies of the present will change
the future and recent research has
revealed a similar pattern in our
individual lives we are unable to
predict change in ourselves three
psychologists documented our inability
to predict personal change in a 2013
paper called the end of history illusion
named after political scientist Francis
Fukuyama's prediction that liberal
democracy was the final form of
government or as he called it the end of
history their work highlights the way we
see ourselves as finished products at
any given moment the researchers
recruited over 7,000 participants ages
18 to 68
they asked half of these participants to
report their current personality traits
values and preferences along with what
each of those metrics had been 10 years
before the other half described those
features in their present selves and
predicted what they would be 10 years in
the future based on these answers the
researchers then calculated the degree
of change each participant reported or
predicted for every age group in the
sample they compared the predicted
changes to the reported changes so they
compared the degree to which 18 year
olds thought they would change to the
degree to which twenty eight year-olds
reported they had changed overwhelmingly
at all ages people's future estimates of
change came up short compared to the
changes their older counterparts
recalled 20 year-olds expected to still
like the same foods at 30 but 30
year-olds know
longer had the same tastes
thirty-year-olds predicted they'd still
have the same bestfriend at 40 but 40
year olds had lost touch with theirs and
40 year olds predicted they've
maintained the same core values that 50
year olds had reconsidered while older
people changed less than younger people
on the whole they underestimated their
capacity for change just as much
wherever we are in life the end of
history illusion persists we tend to
think that the bulk of our personal
change is behind us one consequence of
this thinking is that we're inclined to
over invest in future choices based on
present preferences on average people
are willing to pay about sixty percent
more to see their current favorite
musicians 10 years in the future then
they'd currently pay to see their
favorite musician from 10 years ago
while the stakes involved in concert
going are low we're susceptible to
similar miscalculations in more serious
commitments like homes partners and jobs
at the same time there's no real way to
predict what our preferences will be in
the future without the end of history
illusion it would be difficult to make
any long-term plans so the end of
history illusion applies to our
individual lives but what about the
wider world could we be assuming that
how things are now is how they will
continue to be if so fortunately there
are countless records to remind us that
the world does change sometimes for the
better our own historical moment isn't
the end of history and that can be just
as much a source of comfort as a cause
for concern second-guessing your
decision-making abilities don't worry
we've got you covered here are 5 tips to
improve your critical thinking otherwise
you can head over to our patreon page
and join the community that's helping
bring these lessons to the Internet
[Music]